the three Muslims today I'm going to be
reacting to a video from I am Lucid
titled something along the lines of I
thought I was God without further Ado
let's begin
this is going to be a rather
embarrassing video to make I actually
believed at one point in my life that I
was God
not joking I actually wish that I was
when I first made my Discord server
about four or five years ago I was
introduced to some new age woke uh
atheists that you know kind of led me to
this they influenced me into this belief
that I along with you everybody every
living thing actually the entire
universe itself everything was God just
trying to explore and experience itself
God created all of this to experience
itself as what I actually believed so I
believe that one given point in my life
that I was you
we're just physically in different
bodies but we're the same exact thing
and we're actually one exact Source
that's what I actually came to believe
at one point in my life
this has got me down the deepest darkest
Rabbit Hole depressive state of my life
because I realized that with this type
of thinking there's no justice There's
No Redemption whatsoever if the whole
point of all of this was just to
experience what if you just don't want
to experience what if you want to do
something really really bad to yourself
it doesn't matter there is no justice
right we're all going back to the same
exact place with no reward or punishment
so it's pointless might as well just God
forbid do whatever you want and just
have fun right if somebody came down to
my basement right now hit me with the
control alt delete if you know what I'm
saying that I can't say on YouTube
obviously and uh put me at zero percent
health
if they did it to me right now with that
exact belief they're not going to get
punished for it there's no justice for
it nothing wrong with what they did
because we're just trying to experience
each other that's it that's the whole
point of this so if God came over here
and killed God then God committed no
harm because he stole God right makes no
logical sense but I actually believed in
this because of the first law of
thermodynamics that actually States
energy can be created nor destroyed
so I just want to pause it and jump in
here very quickly uh firstly shout out
to Ian Lou said he's a great brother and
I love how he's debunking this as he
goes in a very logical and rational
manner
um it's very silly how a lot of atheists
are actually very spiritual
and know how he said New Age like
atheists
these are new age spiritual atheists who
don't believe in God
because they're atheists but believe
they are God and everything is God so
they don't believe in God in the
traditional sense but they know that it
doesn't make sense for a god type being
not to exist so they just say oh the
universe and everything is God
come on that what kind of what kind of
nonsense is that that's silly and also
the idea of the first law of
thermodynamics and all that stuff matter
cannot be created nor destroyed only
transferred and so on and so forth
um is to use as an argument it's
fallacious again because that law
applies within a the closed system of
the universe
it applies within a closed system of the
universe how can you say that this
applies without a universe being there
actually there would be no
thermodynamics without a universe or a
container to contain such laws
and such principles
so immediately you know that line of
thinking is is so illogical that if a
person like you know Iron Lucid is
talking about now or to really reflect
on it and think about it they would find
tremendous tremendous gaps in that
thinking in that reasoning
do you think if we're at the smallest
form energy energy can be created or
destroyed then we're God because we're
we're infinite we have no start or end
date so we have to be infinite and if
we're infinite we have to be God that's
what I actually started to believe in I
had full conviction into this belief oh
boy how I can destroy that type of
argument now but I'll give you a few
reasons why this is even more prevalent
in today's time especially amongst the
West so there's a study by the Oxford by
Oxford University that I'm pretty sure
it's a two million dollar study with
like 57 scientists across 22 different
countries that proves and states that
all human beings regardless of whatever
family you're born into all human beings
are born with the innate predisposition
that God exists not only that God exists
but there's an afterlife
it's kind of funny that we're born
knowing that there is one that God
exists and that we're going somewhere
after we die
well in in the west you're taught the
exact opposite it's kind of like they're
going against your own innate
predisposition it's like they're going
against what you were born with
and when you start to go to school in
the West for an example your teachers
teach you that God's not real which is
what happened to me when I was like I
think I was in I think it must have been
like fifth or sixth grade I was taught
that God's not real and that this is all
you know like fake and empirically you
can't prove God so prove to me that God
exists show me God is actually what my
teacher told the entire class of 30 kids
all full of religious backgrounds so
in ninth grade when you get to your
biology class and they teach you that
you are once an ape
a theory by the way a theory the same
way that let's say believing in God is a
theory with it with a missing link
because you can't physically see him or
believing in evolution theory is forced
down your throat as if it's true as if
it's an actual effect so step by step
the schooling system the teachers the
friends the families the the society TV
everywhere you look points to One
Direction that this is a secular place
this is a secular State God's not real
and if you actually believe in it you're
way back in the past behind your like
old school times where we've almost
passed and now we actually follow
science
another great note an amazing note
a spectacular note actually
because it is a huge Injustice it's one
of the the main injustices that occurs
nowadays and nobody really talks about
it because it's something that is
presupposed to be true and correct what
am I talking about
they
Force Upon Us in the scientific this
inductive this empirical this
naturalistic outlook on the world
and claim that these things are
fundamentally true but if I if if they
believe that science is the only way to
come to conclusions right if they
believe science is the only way to come
to conclusions then they fall into a
trap
of you know axiomatic belief
and what makes their axiomatic belief
true and mine not
well there is no real
um demonstration that can prove there's
right or wrong or mind right or wrong uh
naturally
and what do I mean by this let me give
an example if they say the only way to
come to True conclusions is with science
how do they know that can they test it
scientifically
well that would be a circular argument
they would start with science is the
only true way to come to conclusions
the one there's no way to test out
scientifically because even let's say
it's wrong how would you even be able to
prove it's right right and if you were
to basically say Well it produces
results in some kind of pragmatic
Outlook like some atheists have
uh then you would still basically fall
into a circular argument regardless
so this whole approach of of you know
science is the only way to come to True
conclusions is fallacious in and of
itself because the whole claim itself
must be backed by some kind of axiomatic
principle or used in conjunction with
some kind of deduction logical deduction
and now with using logic you're you're
you know opening opening up the doors to
to philosophy and philosophical
arguments and all of that because that's
what philosophy is
um a lot of the time it's just deduction
it's just logic
so
why in that case would you not be able
to bring God into the equation at some
point in a logical sense not in a
scientific sense
also there's a pre supposition
and a kind of
unspoken of but agreed upon rule that in
science you can never
bring God into the equation no matter
what
because the whole belief is that the
Universe exists in a particular manner
and with very specific laws that can be
explained understood observed and and
theorized and so on and so forth
so as soon as they say well you know
this water bottle drops because of God
then you're removing any kind of
naturalistic explanation it's the same
for science it's the same for history
it's the same for anything you know if I
were to tell you why I exist because God
created me
any scientist would be like well no we
don't use that kind of line of thinking
and that's why they have to use some
kind of naturalistic explanation like
Evolution which which Evolution you're
talking about
Darwinism neo-darwinism neogenetics what
kind of dark what kind of um part of me
what kind of evolution are you talking
about here many different theories of
that alone
and that's there's more I want to say on
it but I'll leave it at that inshallah
many many different problems with living
in the West
actually one more thing one main point
actually
this leads to the question why
why do people have this pre this
presupposition that being religious and
being believing in God is is wrong or
incorrect or on I don't say unscientific
because maybe this is some people but
is is wrong and unintelligible an
unintelligent thing to think a lot of
these people think that and act like
that's the case it's because if you look
in the past in Europe and with these
non-muslim civilizations they were so
held back by the church right by
Christian in particular
that once they basically abandoned the
church and adopted a secular way of
living they basically made a covenant
with themselves a promise to themselves
that we will never let any religion look
they they took Christianity and
basically mixed all the religions into
it they said we will not let any belief
in God or any religion dictate our life
for now on our way is that the human
being is free to do to think to believe
whatever they want human beings will
make their own laws their own economics
their own politics everything their own
way
and we will never let religion dictate
our life
and this
Zeal this fire that they had this energy
that they created basically exploded and
went on this trajectory that we are
still on today
when you look back when someone that's
that's the biology teacher comes to you
and says we cannot use God in
explanation
or the the politician comes to you and
they say well we don't let religion
dictate our laws anymore
when you look back why did they say that
where does it come from where is this
police coming from it comes from
secularism where does that come from it
comes from the church repressing
Europeans for like almost a thousand
years
is that Islam's fault no is that
religion's fault no is that God's fault
no
it's the the church's fault it's
Christianity's fault it's those people's
fault at the time
but that's where it comes from
and it's funny because actually
Europeans took a lot from Islam you know
the advancements of Science and Math and
even some laws and legislation they took
a lot of it from Islam from the Muslims
basically
and If Only They had adopted Islam they
would have had the best of both worlds
but since they were so angry with what
the church was doing for so long and
regressing them and repressing them they
compiled all religions under one Banner
of wrong and bad and stupid and
unintelligible
and and they ran with it for all this
time
and that's why we are here today and
they still cannot produce any scientific
evidence that a belief in God is wrong
actually their studies show that we are
bound to believe in God as I am Lucid
mentioned and they cannot produce any
logical rational argument as to why God
does not or cannot exist
quite the contrary is is evident they
don't but they say they do so in the
west when you suppress somebody's
natural desire and need an innate
predisposition to believe that God
exists they end up doing some wacky [__]
to find it other ways right so they end
up even believing that they are God
because they know God has to exist he
just has to they have it built into
their heart they're born knowing it so
the end of when you teach them that no
no God doesn't exist because I can't see
him oh then I I must be him and we all
must be him and everything must be him
that's how this is growing in the west
especially when everyone's lost they
have no objective morality they follow
no objective of law they just kind of go
with what everyone's telling them to do
and they're following their own
subjective desires and saying that
they're good people which is objective
of the impossible
this can be disproven by two ways
the first way is by the contingency
argument this argument basically says
that everything in the universe is
contingent on something else to exist
right so for example for you to be
watching this why everything so if I am
Lucid using the contingency argument
2023 has been good alhamdulillah
man I'm so excited I'm so excited you're
watching this video it's contingent on
YouTube to exist for YouTube to exist
they have to have their YouTube
headquarters and servers because where
else can they store these videos so
let's continue on the servers to exist
and those servers are contingent on the
parent company Google to have bought
them to exist and Google's contingent
you can go forward and back and back and
back and back until we finally get to
the very very start now that start has
to be has to be a necessary thing and it
has to be a non-contingent thing because
if you have an infinite regress of
contingent things nothing could have
given that first order to let the whole
contingent thing even even happen right
so infinitely it cannot regress it's a
fallacy it's actually called the
infinite regress fallacy in philosophy
so we know that there has to be it
necessitates it's necessary for there to
be a non-contingent existence because
everything in the universe is contingent
and if everything in the universe is
contingent it means that it can't be God
because the non-condition has to be
outside of the universe outside of its
creation but the same exact time
infinite
so its reach has to extend within the
entire creation the same way that a
painter kind of like a good analogy same
way that a painter can paint something
but the painter isn't inside the
painting right or a carpenter can make
this desk but the carpenter isn't inside
the desk same exact way that God can
create us but we are not God we're a
creation of God that if that makes sense
to you for an example there's a line of
dominoes from me to you I hit the first
Domino let's say I'm the necessary being
I hit the first Domino and then that
makes a contingent Trail all the way to
you
then you say no it was infinitely
contingent it can't be there had to be a
necessary being that let the first
domino fall same exact concept with us
that's why there has to be one Divine
source of God
just add to it very quickly basically to
summarize the internet regression
fallacy if everything that exists
depended on something before then
nothing would exist because you'd go
back into infinity and if you go back at
infinitum or back into Infinity then is
never ending which means that the chain
of things that exist would never begin
to begin with
that's why I truly believe in it because
logically rationally and uh where and
innately we're born believing in this it
just makes sense next there is the
second law of Thermodynamics I mentioned
the first one right which is energy can
be created nor destroyed which means yo
we're God which is what I actually
believed but the second one states that
energy will continue to increase in
entropy entropy is like a disorder for
energy so there's there's no perfect
transformation of energy it's always
increasing in disorder over time I
actually this this point is so important
I actually traveled across the world
like a 16-hour flight to Turkey to prove
this on the other biggest Islamic
YouTube channel the video should be out
within like the next month or so I
traveled across the world to convey this
exact message because of how important
it was
I'll give you one example if I place a
space heater in the back of this room
and then I turn it on and then turn it
off after like one hour the heat will
eventually dissipate throughout the
entire basement and then raise the level
of temperature maybe just by a little
bit maybe like one or two degrees right
so the heat won't stay exactly in that
corner even though that's where it
started off is because there's a
transformation of energy the energy is
becoming it's increasing towards
uniformity now that's not only happening
in my basement
and I am Lucid YouTube Studio that
you've subscribed to but that's also
happening you've also subscribed right
I'm just making sure that's also
happening in the entire universe the
whole universe is increasing in an
entropy so even though the energy
technically can be created or destroyed
it will uh continually increase in
entropy and Disorder so that that means
that not only did we have a start date
because of the Big Bang but we also are
going to have an end date proved
scientifically the universe will not
last forever one Google search will give
you a thousand reasons why but the
universe is not going to exist forever
it's not infinite and if the universe is
God
and the universe is not infinite the
universe cannot be God because by
definition like we said God has to be a
non-contingent he has to be infinite he
has to be outside of the bounds of time
space and matter because he had to have
created it otherwise if he didn't he's
not God right
so with that type of thinking I realized
there's no way there it makes no Lush
rational logical sense that I am God and
that you are God and the whole universe
is God because if God has a start date
and an end date then that must mean that
this whatever this thing is this whole
universe is a creation of God of
something that doesn't doesn't have a
start date or
again just to jump in
imagine I were to ask you if you had a
completely flat surface or a completely
flat Lane that went on for like Infinity
and I asked you if I rolled this bowling
ball on this Lane
how long would it take for the bowling
ball to eventually stop
you would answer it depends on how hard
you throw it if I throw out as light as
I possibly can it would roll for maybe
like a second or two and then stop and
if I throw it as hard as I can maybe
it'd roll for like a minute maybe two
minutes because I'm very strong
alhamdulillah and then it would stop now
imagine this on a universal level the
big bang and I'm making this very like
it's a very reductionist argument it's
very simple but I want everyone to be
able to understand inshallah the Big
Bang was basically produced an explosion
that's so powerful you your mind can't
comprehend it
so if I were to throw a bowling ball
with that kind of energy it would go on
for like it would seem like forever
but in all honesty in all actuality it
cannot physically go on forever
eventually
it would use up the energy and because
of the friction on the floor it would
even out
and there'd be no more forces acting on
it right it would run out of energy in
in its movement in its momentum it would
run out of that momentum same thing with
the universe
in every way from a and uh the
perspective of energy
um it's not just physical but like in
terms of the energy of the Universe
um it cannot be something that is
self-sufficient self-sustaining so there
is an explosion the big bang and it sent
everything flying out but I cannot go
flying out forever
eventually it'll stop and it's the same
thing for example our solar system
there are forces acting on the planets
that are causing them to rotate that are
causing them to orbit now it seems like
this is going to go on forever
but it's not actually going on forever
it's just due to the the immense energy
and the the force of of you know the
gravitational forces that certain
celestial bodies have in the um in the
universe it's just due to those things
that they are basically orbiting for as
long as they have been but eventually
things as far as I know will fall out of
orbit they will lose that momentum
they will lose that you know that energy
the potential energy that they currently
have to keep going
and eventually everything will cease to
exist
very scary or an ending that is the
uncreated creator that is the uncaused
cause that hit the first Domino and made
them all fall for a lack of better term
that is the prime mover that's what God
is
so that's where I came I came an
extremely long way I'm actually shocked
I'm still alive to convey this message
because of how deeply depressed this
ideology got me if you live in the west
don't follow this this stupid secular
type of thinking where God's an old it's
just the old tell these old religions
are all old fake BS and you just kind of
dismiss them because we we follow
science now like look how cool we are we
follow science and then really that's
honestly not the case and a lot of our
theories are still either baseless
disproven or had a big missing link
right in the middle of them so don't
have that big ego on your shoulders
because you live in America you feel
like you don't have to believe in God
that's not how it works at least try to
disprove God to me then we can start
talking you can't just say it doesn't
exist because I can't see him if you
could see him he wouldn't be God
we have these discussions nearly every
single day in my Discord server that's a
discord.gg lucid either in the pin
comment Down Below in my description you
can find the link anywhere just freaking
join my Discord server it's scroll down
a little bit you will definitely find it
we have these debates we're going to
start holding stages in my Discord
server like kind of like Clubhouse where
there's like two guys debating and
there's a big audience listening so if
you would like to debate on any topic
like this if you're an educated atheist
even if you don't even hold any of my
stances I would love to see you in there
so that I can at least hear your point
of view and we can have some of the uh
you know smart brothers and sisters kind
of debate you in there that'd be a great
time honestly be a great thing to watch
I'm actually looking forward to it
myself thank you for watching this video
Stay dreaming stay Lucid I'm out peace
all right again may Allah bless our
brother I am lucid and reward him Allah
I mean amazing video and I did not
expect it to take the turn that it did
so I'm very happy with that
alhamdulillah he has come a long way
from what I can see so may Allah
increase him and continue to increase I
mean so I think it was a great note that
he ended on
um there isn't really much I could say
except that um
just go where the evidences if anyone
makes a claim to you verify it no matter
what it is no matter how scary it might
seem just investigate it
you know if God is real and Islam is
true then reality will basically
emphasize that belief
or at the very least will not contradict
that belief
so with that being said may Allah bless
you all for watching and I'll see you
guys in the next one